yes I'm very excited to announce that
Megan and myself had a baby boy early
this morning and very healthy boy mother
and baby are doing incredibly well it's
been the most amazing experience I can
ever possibly imagine how any woman does
what they do is beyond comprehension but
we're both absolutely thrilled and so
grateful to all the love and support for
everybody out there from everybody out
there it's been it's been amazing so we
just wanted to share this with everybody
still think about names on it's the
babies a little bit overdue so we've had
a little bit time to think about it but
some yeah mister that's that's but
that's the next fit but for us I think
we'll be seeing you guys in probably two
days time as planned as a family to be
able to show it with you guys and so one
can see the baby I haven't been in many
births this is definitely my first boy
beer is amazing absolutely incredible
and as I said I'm so incredibly proud of
my wife and as every father and parent
would ever say you know your your babies
absolutely amazing but this little thing
is absolutely to die for so I'm just
over the moon thank you very much guys